this is the one piece Iceberg it's split
into seven parts and made up of 37
theories in total the first stage
consists of mostly mainstream popular
theories youve probably heard of before
but as we go further through the stages
the theories will start to get
progressively weirder until they become
straight up insane and let's start with
a really well-known one Blackbeard has
multiple personalities Theory aside from
being one of the most hated characters
Marshall D teach AKA Blackbeard is also
well known for his cunningness
ruthlessness and cowardice which is a
pretty weird combination of TR for one
person to have he's also the only person
in the story to have the power of two
devil fruits yummy yummy Nomi and gura
gura Nomi it's common knowledge that
anyone who eats two devil fruits dies
which brings us to the question how is
this possible it has been pretty heavily
theorized by fans that Blackbeard has
more than one personality within him
which would explain some of his weird
Behavior also it's important to mention
that he never sleeps possibly because
one of his personalities is always awake
and lastly during GA both Zoro and Luffy
referred to him as they and not not he
which just further proves that he may be
more than one person a new Straw Hat
near the beginning of the story Luffy
mentioned that he wanted 10 crew mates
on a ship currently there are only nine
straw hats excluding Luffy which means
that it's very likely we'll get to see
another crewmate before the story ends
there are a lot of speculations about
who the last straw hat may be the most
obvious choice would be Vivi the
princess of the alabasta Kingdom another
potential member is Yamato however
considering he decided to stay in wano
after the battle I think it's unlikely
he'll be joining the crew some other can
are bartolomew Bonnie carrot or maybe
even a new character we don't know yet
the crocodile Theory this next theory is
the one that's had the one piece fandom
in a choke cold ever since the early one
piece it's a theory about crocodile
former warlord of the sea actually being
a woman if you never heard this Theory
before your first reaction is probably
wait what but bear with me during the
impel down Arc before crocodile was
released from his cell by Luffy ianov
threatened to spill his darkest secret
if he decided to betray them now we all
know that the okama queen has devil
fruit powers that can alter a person's
body including their sex this made one
piece fans speculate that at some point
ianov had transformed crocodile from
female to male now believe it or not
there are actually some hints to this
theory in the newly released one piece
live action during Roger's execution we
can clearly see a bunch of important
people in the crowd such as Dragon
Shanks and mihawk however there's one
unknown female in the crowd that got a
lot of attention in this scene for some
reason since we know that crocodile was
there in lown during rers execution a
lot of people think that this woman is
actually crocodile I don't know about
you guys but I can definitely see some
resemblance before we continue down the
iceberg I want to let you guys know that
this video has a special sponsor you'll
absolutely love Zen Market if you're
anything like me you probably love
collecting anime figures however in most
of the world these things aren't easy to
get especially the newly released ones
but that's where Zen Market comes in
it's a service that allows you to buy
stuff directly from Japan and ship ship
them to your doorstep whether you want
to buy anime merch manga volumes or
maybe even some Pokémon cards you'll
find exactly what you're looking for as
Zen Market allows you to order from over
10,000 Japanese stores for example check
out this cool Shanks figure I found on
Japanese Amazon Zen Market can buy it
for me and ship it globally for only a
little over 30 bucks wait this is
actually a pretty good deal let me just
order this real quick there we go
currently there's a sale going on in the
Ruma store and if you order anything
from there you'll get 7% cash back on
whatever you spend if you ever wanted to
order something from Japan now is
probably the best time and since you're
a loyal viewer of the channel you can
also use the special promo code Jager
wrists to get 739 Yen off the
international shipping fee what are you
waiting for click the link in the
description and order some of these
amazing things now the final war it's
been hinted multiple times throughout
the series that the one piece story will
end with one huge War this war was first
mentioned by Whitebeard when he said
that the world government feared the
immense battle that would come one day
this was later confirmed by the narrator
during dress Roso when he said that
Luffy's Fleet would cause an incident
that would go down in history this Final
War will most likely be an allout battle
against the world government with every
important pirate throughout the world
participating according to Oda the
creator of One Piece the final war will
make the Marine forward war look like
Child's Play in comparison dragon has a
weather manipulation devil fruit power
even in the early onepiece Dragon the
leader of the Revolutionary Army has
always been associated with weather for
example when he first appeared at l
toown it rained heavily the gunpowder
had been soaked so the soldiers couldn't
fire their guns and even a windstorm
blew some of them away also when buggy
tried to execute Luffy the podium was
struck by lightning conveniently saving
Luffy at the last moment besides this
there was also instances where dragons
slightly levitated in the air while wind
was seen beneath him although we don't
know the exact devil fruit power dragon
has most fans can agree that it's most
likely some kind of weather paramia
however if you want to get more creative
about it it's also possible that dragon
has a mythical Zan fruit model shenlong
shenlong is a dragon from Chinese
mythology that's known as the master of
rain the meaning of d one of the most
mysterious things in the entire show is
the initial D the leading theory so far
is that d stands for Dawn and that those
who have D in their names would bring
about a new dawn in the world there's
actually a lot of hints as to why this
may be true first of all the first Arc
in the series is called romance Dawn the
word dawn has also been mentioned by
minks when they spoke of the one who
would bring about a new dawn Toki also
mentions a new dawn in her prophecy same
as the samurai when BOS yogoro mentions
wano seeing a new dawn after kaido is
defeated now to elaborate on this Theory
even more a lot of fans believe that D
also represents the members of Joy boy's
crew the dawn Pirates during the void
Century they all took up the name d as a
symbol of their loyalty and friendship
and as a result their descendants
carried the name d this ties pretty well
with recent developments in the manga
where U stated that D is an initial
carried by their ancient enemies which
in this case could be the dawn Pirates
and with that the first stage of the
iceberg is finished the theories up
ahead are still pretty well known but
there may be some you didn't know about
Luffy will will die at the end of one
piece as the protagonist of the story
it's widely believed that after
everything comes to an end luy will
achieve everything he wants and live a
happy life although that's true for the
vast majority of anime protagonists it
may not apply to Luffy as a lot of fans
speculate that he'll actually die at the
end you see throughout the course of the
manga there's been hints about Luffy's
reduced lifespan his devil fruit Powers
have been known to take a big strain on
his body gears 2 and three in particular
Luffy is constantly pushing his body to
the absolute limits and with each new
transformation it only gets worse and
worse then there was the time at impel
down when Emporio evov injected Luffy
with healing hormones which resulted in
him losing 10 years worth of his
lifespan and not to mention the
additional adrenaline shots he received
multiple times even after Ivon warned
him of risks to his health all in all if
Luffy continues going at this pace it's
a real possibility that the Stray won't
end that well for him Shanks is a
Celestial Dragon throughout the show
Shanks has been able to pull off a lot
of suspicious things that wouldn't be
possible for a normal pirate for example
even though he's an emperor of the sea
he was somehow granted an audience with
five Elders H something's telling me
kaido or Blackbeard wouldn't be allowed
to do that he was also able to stop the
war at Marine Ford and the fleet Admiral
sangoku even allowed him to take Aces
and whitebeard's bodies furthermore it's
theorized that Shanks was actually born
in God's Valley and after the battle
with rocks Roger found him and decided
to raise him this would make sense since
we know a lot of celestial dragons were
on the island during the battle the
timeline also works perfectly here as
the god Valley incident happened 38
years ago while Shanks is exactly 39
years old Luffy destroys the red line
using one piece even after a thousand
plus chapters of the manga otus still
hasn't revealed to us what the one piece
actually is however the theory that
it'll somehow help Luffy destroy the red
line and unite all the oceans makes just
way too much sense first of all it would
make most of the crew's dreams come true
since all four seas would be connected
Sanji would find the all blue Rook would
reunite with laboon and Nami would be
able to draw a map of the entire world
Also let's not forget that merging all
the oceans together and getting rid of
this line in the the middle will
literally make the world be in one piece
this would also make Madam Shirley's
prediction of Luffy destroying fisherman
Island come true as it's located under
the red line Blackbeard Cerberus Theory
we've already discussed a theory about
Blackbeard and his three personalities
but now let's take it a step further
what if the reason Blackbeard has these
personalities is because he ate a
mythical Zan devil fruit model Cerberus
in Greek mythology serverus is described
as the three-headed dog that guards the
gates of the underworld this would be
really fitting for Blackbeard as he's
known to have some kind of connection to
the number three three skulls on his
Jolly Roger the three-bladed claw he
used to slash Shanks his beard being
split into three parts and even three
pistols he always carries around this
connection is why a lot of fans believe
that Blackbeard also has three different
people within him same as how Cerberus
has three heads aliji is a spy aliji has
always had a strong sense of justice and
always did what he felt was right this
is why when it was revealed post-time
skip that he became one of the 10
Titanic captains of the Blackbeard
Pirates it came as a shock why would he
agree to work work for Blackbeard even
though he claimed he had joined them
because he wanted to live for himself
and be free when smoker mentioned his
involvement with the underworld Kuan
reassured him by saying he was still the
same person but how can he be the same
person he always was and being the most
evil pirate crew in the world at the
same time it doesn't really makes sense
this is why a lot of fans think that
Kuan is actually a spy and has joined
the Blackbeard pirates only to learn
what they're planning but if he's not
working for the Blackbeard Pirates Who
is he working for one option could be
that he's a sword agent just like Drake
who infil traed the Beast Pirates or he
could be working with the revolution
Army just like Kuma had been while he
was a warlord no matter how you spin it
this guy just doesn't belong in
Blackbeard's crew Usopp and elb elff was
first mentioned during the little garden
arc when the straw hats met Dy and broi
the leaders of the giant Pirates Usopp
was so inspired by them that he started
to dream of one day going to elath and
meeting the proud Warriors there it's
pretty much confirmed that the next
destination for the straw hats is going
to be elb and many fans expect Usopp to
play a really important role during this
art we all know how most of usopp's Lies
eventually come true in the end however
some of the lies that still didn't come
true are that he has conqueror's hockey
and that he'll lead the army of 8,000
soldiers well isn't elff a perfect Arc
for Uso to finally achieve these things
and become the great warrior of the sea
but how exactly will this happen one
theory is that hydrogen a giant we were
introduced to in drosa will tell
everyone the story about Brave God Usopp
who freed everyone from doflamingo's
control this story will make Giants
acknowledge usopp's bravery and consider
him worthy of leading them okay let's
kick off the third stage with the
weirdest Theory so far the hidden power
behind zoro's left eye aside from the
evident improvements in his
swordsmanship and hockey during the time
skip zotto also acquired a big scar on
his left eye the most obvious answer
would be that he lost it during his
training with mihawk but that doesn't
sound that interesting so fans came up
with a bunch of theories about zodo's
closed eye some fans joked about zodo
keeping his eye closed because of his
shutting gun and ring gun which he
acquired after getting lost and ending
up in the hidden Leaf Village although
this is entirely Poss possible the other
fans have some more grounded theories
Jokes Aside their speculations that
during their training mihawk noticed
that zoro's left eye was more dominant
than his right eye and instructed him to
keep it closed so he could train his
weaker eye so when zodo eventually opens
his left eye he'll have far superior
Vision which will instantly become much
stronger nl's return after nl's defeat
during skypia he went to the moon and
pretty much became God there some of you
may be confused as this was never shown
in the anime but it is actually Canon as
it's one of the manga cover stories
anyway on the moon an L defeated space
pirates and brought back life to an army
of robots he also discovered that the
shandians lived on the moon a long time
ago before they traveled to the Earth
because of the lack of resources Oda the
creator of one piece is known to
constantly bring back old characters
especially the ones featured in cover
stories like wapple cp9 agents and buggy
this is brought forth speculation that
NL could return at some point to share
his knowledge and may even play a part
in revealing things about the void
sentury he could even play a part in the
final war we talked about before Shiki
visits crocus Shiki the Golden Lion aka
the flying pirate is a former member of
Rock's Pirates as well as one of Rogers
biggest Rivals although Shiki is a Canon
character he never made an appearance in
the anime however there's something
really interesting to be seen on the
cover page of chapter 631 on this panel
we can see that someone is having a
friendly chat with crocus the former
doctor of the Rogers Pirates who's
currently taking care of laboon near the
entrance to the Grand line even though
it was never officially confirmed this
mysterious figure looks a lot like Chiki
his hair his ape and even the color of
his clothes are exactly the same as his
while some argue that this is a
foreshadowing that Shiki will eventually
return to the main story others believe
it's a way of showing his story has been
concluded and he's now enjoying life
reconnecting with old acquaintances
mihawk's parents even though we were
introduced to mihawk very early into the
show to this day we know nothing about
his origin and parents however a lot of
fans me included believe that Ry and
shaki are his parents first of all he
physically resembles them a lot his hair
ears sideburns the way his beard is
shaped and even the way he dresses are
really similar to them also their age
works really well with this Theory
because if mihawk is their child it
would mean that they were 34 and 20 when
he was born which is pretty believable
another important thing to mention is
that mihawk wore a shirt with peones
during Roger's execution the reason I'm
mentioning this is because shaki's full
name shakuyaku literally means peones in
Japanese which could hint towards the
connection between the two Luffy will
get Roger sickness the former pirate
king Goldie Roger had been suffering
from an incurable disease near the end
of his career and even with crocus his
help he knew he wouldn't live for much
longer although there's many theories
that try to explain how Roger got his
illness it's possible that it's due to
him constantly overexerting himself in a
similar way to Luffy having many
near-death experiences and often pushing
himself to the limits now you all know
how Roger and Luffy are pretty much the
same in many aspects they even say the
exact same words sometimes this
connection between them could mean that
Luffy will eventually share the same
fate as Roger and get sick when he
becomes the p pirate king Shanks was
going to give gugun Nomi to Ace we
learned from Who's Who and wano that
Shanks came into possession of the gugun
Nomi after he attacked the marine Vessel
transporting it however after that for
some reason he didn't do anything with
the fruit and instead went to this
random village where he spent the
majority of his time could it be that
the real reason Shanks was there was
because he was searching for his
Captain's son Ace it's possible that
Shanks initially stole the gag Nomi
because he wanted to give it to Ace so
he could find the laugh tale and fulfill
the dream Roger couldn't Luffy eating
the fruit was never part of the plan and
that's why Shanks was so surprised about
it but he figured that it must have been
fate and let Luffy have it after that he
left fusha Village and never returned
again because his mission was fulfilled
four more stages of the iceberger left
and if you knew all the theories so far
you're a real one piece fan
congratulations however let's see if you
can keep up uto Jackson egg at one point
during the one Piece Film strong world
we see something really weird on Roger
ship a large egg with red dots although
we never got an explanation as to what
this egg actually is during that spefic
specific scene Shiki mentioned that he
wanted to take an apocalyptic weapon
Roger had in his possession could it be
that this mysterious weapon he was
talking about is somehow related to this
egg what's even weirder is that Roger's
crew was saved by the sudden storm that
sunk most of shiki's Fleet and you know
what's rumored to have the power of sky
and Heavens that's right the ancient
weapon Uranus even though this is purely
speculation it's possible that Roger
found an egg from which yanus would be
born and its power kept him safe from
shiki's Fleet Luffy's true dream
everyone knows Luffy's dream is to be
free and become the pirate king however
recently in the sty we learned that this
isn't Luffy's real dream in chapter 1000
Ace reveals Luffy's true dream to yam
and although we don't hear what it is
his reaction to it is shock and awe
realizing that it's the exact same dream
Roger had it also made him laugh which
was something Ace and Sabo did when he
first mentioned it to them as children
we all know that one of the things Luffy
likes the most his parties and he throws
one at the end of pretty much every Arc
based on this and his childlike
personality it's entirely possible that
his dream would be to throw the world's
largest party this would explain why
everyone who's heard his dream laughed
as it's such a ridiculous dream to have
it would also tie in well with one piece
theme of Freedom as everyone no matter
the race would be treated equally and
have fun together devil fruit users
can't go to laugh Tale in order to get
to the laugh tale someone needs to find
and read all road poneglyphs but even
that isn't common knowledge and very few
people know where these stones are
located however is it possible that
there's another reason laugh tail is so
hard to reach could it be that fruit
users are prohibited from entering the
final Island the reason I'm saying this
is because when the Roger Pirates were
heading to laugh taale buggy and Toki
the only two devil fruit users on Roger
ship got extremely sick this led to Toki
returning to wano while Shanks stayed
behind with buggy to nurse him until he
got better that's a pretty weird
coincidence isn't it another thing is
that in recent chapters Shanks declared
that it's finally time for his pirate
crew to claim one piece to the best of
our knowledge no member of the red hair
Pirates has any devil fruit abilities
could it be that the reason Shanks
waited for so long to get the one piece
was because he knew that no other crew
would ever be able to find it because of
their devil fruit Powers Luffy's mom is
a Celestial Dragon like a lot of
characters in one piece Luffy's mother
is a big mystery and we have no
information regarding her identity not
once has there been any talk about her
although there's a lot of theories about
Luffy's mom the most popular one is that
she's actually a Celestial Dragon
there's pretty much nothing backing this
Theory but it's possible that she met
Dragon will he was on some business
related to the Revolutionary Army and
fell in love with him she then wanted to
give Luffy a nor Al life and sent him to
live on fusa island Luffy's final bounty
after every major arc the straw hats are
awarded with new bounties after becoming
a young Co Luffy's bounty was raised to
3 billion berries which leads to the
question how high could Luffy's bounty
go I don't know if you knew this but
there's actually a word play on the
numbers of each yonko Bounty a sort of
pun created by Oda for example big
bomb's Bounty is 4 b388 million if we
take the last two numbers which are 88
and pronounce them in Japanese we'll get
haha which means mother the last numbers
of white Beard's Bounty are 46 which can
be pronounced as Shiro meaning white in
Japanese for kaido it's hakuu meaning
100 beasts and for Shanks and Roger it's
shaku and roshia referring to their
names anyway all these word plays led to
the speculation that Luffy's final
Bounty at the end of the series will be
5 b656 million berries this is because
the numbers 5656 could be pronounced as
gugu referring to Luffy's devil fruit
but let's go even deeper than that to
the fifth stage and the theory that
states that doflamingo and gecko Maria
will join the cross Guild there have
been talks recently of Oda playing with
the idea of another impel down breakout
during this breakout doflamingo will
escape and along the way he'll encounter
crocodile who would invite him to join
the crew with his knowledge of what
secret the world government is trying to
hide in his ties to the underworld he
would be a logical Ally for the cross
Guild also Oda recently brought Maria
back to the story and it's likely he'll
soon escape from Blackbeard's captivity
with perona after this due to perona's
connection to mihawk she would convince
him to allow Maria to join them this
would be really interesting to see as it
would mean that five forber Warlords
would be on the crew together the last
road poneglyph so far in the story we've
only heard the locations of three Road
poneglyphs one is at zo one at hake and
one in wano this leads to the question
where is the last one we know that at
one point it was located on Fishman
Island but nobody has seen it since then
before disbanding his crew Roger said
something to Shanks that we didn't get
to hear could it be that Roger
instructed him to hide the last Road
poneglyph in a wait Joy boy's return
this could also explain why he stole G
noi from the world government as he
wanted to make sure that it would end up
in the right hands if we believe this to
be the case the location of the last
poneglyph is most likely to be elath
this is because the island is shank's
territory and is not affiliated with the
world government which makes it the
perfect hiding spot for the fourth Road
poneglyph Kuma will join the straw hats
considering the manga is slowly entering
its final stage it would make sense that
anyone joining the straw hats is someone
we're already familiar with Guma has
ties with the crew he had once saved
them on salv and he Protected Their ship
during the 2-year time skip not to
mention his connection with Sabo and
dragon but there's more to this Theory
you see the straw hats have four devil
fruit users and each of their fruits can
relate to the numbers between 1 and 10
Luffy's fruit gumu can be read as 5 six
Choppers heito is 110 Robins Hama is 87
and Brooks yomi is 43 this only leaves
numbers 2 and N missing so could it be
that the new crew mate will have a devil
fruit that can be read as 29 well it's
possible enum is the perfect candidate
as his devil fruit niku niku noi can be
read as 29 niku the straw hats and the
black beard Pirates will play Davy back
fight the Davy back fight was first
introduced during the long ring longland
art and since then we haven't heard much
about it Robin mentioned the game was
invented on Pirate Island and it served
as a way for captains to fight over the
best possible Sailors for their crew now
the interesting thing is that the
Blackbeard's base of operations is haosu
which is literally known as Pirate
Island this could mean that when it
comes time for Luffy and Blackbeard to
fight they'll do Deb back fight instead
the straw hats will want to take aliji
and Blackbeard will want Robin because
of her ability to read poneglyphs shaki
was a member of the Rocks Pirates
shakuyaku ry's wife and bartender of
shaki's ripoff bar once said that her
pirating career ended around 40 years
ago although she never stated which
pirate crew she was a part of there's a
crew that disbanded almost exactly 40
years ago the Rocks pirates in the Rock
crew there was this one character called
Silver Axe and although we literally
don't know anything about them I guess
it's possible that this character is
actually shocky one fan brought this up
to Oda and he replied I don't know what
you mean d do could this mean that there
really is something to this Theory or is
Oda just messing with us before we cover
the final seventh stage with some of the
weirdest theories you'll ever hear let's
first go over the sixth stage which is
also packed with pretty weird theories
like this one that states that
Blackbeard and Luffy will fight together
except for Rox D zebic all members of
the D Clan are good people who try to
help others since Blackbeard is also
part of the D Clan it must mean that
he's good too and could even end up
fighting alongside Luffy against the
world government the reason he's doing
all these evil things now is simply to
prepare for that upcoming fight and he
believes that all of the bad things he's
done will be justified in the end kizaru
will betray the Marines Admiral kizaru
the user of pikap piki is one of the
Navy's strongest Fighters and one of the
crew's major enemies however in the end
there's a chance that he could end up
being Luffy's Ally there are a few
things backing this Theory the first one
is that on sa it was almost as if he was
just toying with the straw hats which
ultimately gave Kuma the opportunity to
help them Escape look at how powerful he
is capturing or killing them would have
been Child's Play for him so is it
possible that he let them go on on
purpose also during the brain Ford War
while Luffy was lying on the ground
instead of finishing him off kizaru just
kicked him toward Whitebeard another
interesting thing is that his Justice is
described as unclear which could mean
that he'll end up switching sides in the
future Kina is alive since the
introduction of tashiki in log toown
fans have been speculating that she is
kuina zoro's childhood friend and the
person he made a promise to although not
likely it's possible that Kina didn't
die like Zoro thought and instead lost
her memories after the accident a good
argument for this theory is that Oda
rarely kills characters and the whole
fell down the stairs thing seems a bit
weird even though Oda released a picture
of a young tashiki which basically
disproved the theory many still believe
he did it to hide something and he would
reveal it in due time the straw hats
will go to the Moon the Moon seems to be
a really important part of One Piece
it's been mentioned a few times and it
also appears in a lot of important
scenes from nl's cover story we
discussed earlier it's obvious that the
moon holds a lot of secrets that are
important to the story so could it be
that the one piece is also located there
maybe laugh tale is just another clue on
how to get there you have to admit that
this would be pretty hilarious and it
would explain why Roger laughs so hard
when he reached the final Island and
finally the seventh stage of the iceberg
buillt with some of the most absurd
theories you ever heard ORS is Joy boy
okay I know this sounds absolutely
ridiculous but let's go through a few
clues that support this Theory firstly
the giant Straw Hat emu is looking at in
the Holy Land Mary giosi Bears a
striking resemblance to Luffy's own
straw hat and considering its size it
looks like it would be a perfect fit for
ores also during triller bark after
Maria revived ores using Luffy's Shadow
he claimed that Luffy was a perfect fit
for ores since we now know that Luffy is
a new Joy boy could that be the reason
why his shadow was so fitting and lastly
or seemed to like Luffy's Straw Hat a
lot and wanted to wear it this could be
because Luffy's Shadow was inside him
but it could also be that he remembered
it from a long time ago mihawk is yodu
so what if mihawk doesn't actually exist
and he's only the physical manifestation
of the sword yodu it was hinted multiple
times throughout one piece that certain
devil fruits and swords have souls and
personalities of their own so could it
be that Yu took a physical manifestation
in the form of mihawk and an attempt to
find the person worthy enough to wield
it the fact that mihawk let zodo live
during bti could also tie in well with
this Theory as yodu has probably seen
zodo's potential and decided to wait and
see if he'll become the man worthy of
wielding it it is also said a blade
looks into people and chooses the best
person who suits it similar to how zodo
mentioned enma was testing him mihawk or
in this case yodu probably looked into
zodo and found him worthy which is why
it acknowledged him and agreed to train
him Rock Pirates are all cloned we know
that Stuy is the clone of bakim who is a
former member of Rock's Pirates but what
if there's even more clones of this
legendary crew for obvious reasons
Weevil could be whitebeard's clone
Bonnie could be big mom's clone based on
their similar appearances and habits
Blackbeard could be the clone of the man
himself Rox D zebic and since he was a
failed project it could explain his
weird behavior embod and lastly yam
could be kaido's clone as his mother was
never mentioned Queen kaido's second in
command once worked together with Vega
Punk so I guess it's possible he was the
one who made yamel zodo will betray
Luffy in the end before becoming a
member of the straw hats zodo was a
famed pirate Hunter who was known to go
after the pirates with the highest
Bounty so what if the only reason zodo
joined the crew is to help Luffy become
the pirate king so he can cash in on his
huge bounty in the end I mean think
about it even after being a pirate for 3
years his epithet is still pirate Hunter
isn't that a bit weird the one piece is
inside Luffy this one is pretty
straightforward the pirate Treasures are
always marked with an x on maps So based
on this it makes perfect sense that the
X on Luffy's chest marks the place where
the one piece is man I can't believe
Roger's great treasure has literally
been in front of our noses this whole
time click on this video where we rank
the top 15 strongest swordsman in one
piece